throw up the warning we're going to The
View
Whoopi Goldberg who has become a very
successful black woman who uh that's not
her real name I believe her real name is
Karen Johnson decided to take a Jewish
last name I don't know if that's
cultural appropriation or not she used
to be decent lost her mind you guys know
that listen to what she says about Tim
Scott right here
I think one of the issues that Tim Scott
has is that he seems to think because I
made it everyone can make it ignoring
again the fact that he is the exception
and not the rule and until he is the
rule then he can stop talking about
systems
he has Clarence Thomas syndrome
man you you these are not good people
look Sunny Hosten I know you know Sunny
hosten's not good he's the exception not
the rule well the rule all the rule can
be is that we can create a society
hopefully that gets out of the way
enough so everyone has an equal chance
and that's what we've got
you know and everyone could sit there
and complain about what their ancestors
went through every single every single
one of you watching this almost without
exception unless your parents your
great-great-grandparents were like
Aristocrats or before that they were
kings and queens and you could probably
figure out a way that they were
oppressed too but every single person
watching this wherever your great
grandparents came your ancestors came
from it was shitty that's the whole
point of America and that these people
then look at people who succeed like
Clarence Thomas
like Tim Scott Etc and they resent them
for that
they resent them for that
right like you shouldn't be on that
television show uh Sunny Hosten you are
an untalented unpleasant
uh Wench but you're on that show and
guess what it has a little something to
do with you being black because if you
were that unpleasant and that uneducated
that nasty as a white woman you wouldn't
have got the gig so you might want to
look in the mirror
[Music]
oh